for Greeks this has been the last five
years street protests budget cuts higher
taxes and a breakdown of government
services now they're being given a
choice in how to save the country on
July fifth they'll vote in a referendum
a yes vote means agreeing to more tough
measures imposed by the international
institutions lending Greece money a no
vote means rejecting these bailout
conditions and possibly leaving the euro
but how did it come to this before the
global financial crisis Greece paid off
its debt the same way many other
countries did by borrowing even more
money after the crisis hit banks became
a lot more reluctant to lend money
suddenly Greece had massive payments due
and no cash to pay them off the IMF the
European Commission and the European
Central Bank also known as the troika
offered to bail out Greece and lend it
money to pay back the banks but only
under certain conditions that Greece cut
back its public spending and hiked up
taxes what economists call austerity
these austerity measures also meant mass
firings and very tough times across the
country five years on the Greek economy
isn't doing much better twenty five
percent of Greeks are unemployed and
twenty-seven percent living poverty for
young Greeks it's even worse sixty
percent of them can't get a job and
their parents and grandparents are
losing their pensions and remember the
bailout money doesn't even go to the
Greek people it goes to the foreign
banks that greets all his money too with
part of the debt due on june thirtieth
Greek Prime Minister Alexis tsipras has
called the troika's latest bailout
conditions humiliating and said he
wouldn't accept them unless the Greek
people voted for them in a referendum
the government has ordered banks to
close until the day after the vote and
has limited ATM withdrawals to avoid
money rushing out of the country if
Greeks agree to the bailout conditions
Greece will stay in the eurozone but
it'll mean more of the same hardship and
poverty if they say no things won't get
much better Greece will probably default
on its loans
could result in a domino effect it could
be forced to leave the Euro money would
rush out of the country and it wouldn't
be able to borrow any more there would
be severe inflation and a long recession
it would also set a precedent for other
eurozone countries with massive debts
and that worries Europe's richer
countries who are owed that debt but at
least after the chaos and long period of
economic struggle Greece would finally
be able to reclaim control over its own
finances
you